tensions erupted during a Catholic Mass
as the Archbishop of Washington DC
addressed the clergy sex abuse scandal a
[Music]
protester interrupted Cardinal Donald
Wuerl Sunday as he pleaded for loyalty
to Pope Francis world has faced calls to
resign since a grand jury report
revealed abuses that occurred during his
time as the head of the Pittsburgh
diocese Nicky - Nicky batiste is
following the growing turmoil Nicky good
morning good morning the heckler was
reportedly upset with the Catholic
Church's lack of transparency throughout
decades of alleged sexual abuse the
disruption came when Cardinal Wuerl
asked the Congregation to keep Pope
Francis in their prayers after the
interruption during his Sunday sermon
Cardinal Donald Wuerl apologized for how
he and a Catholic Church handled the
clergy sexual abuse scandal
last month a Pennsylvania grand jury
report found more than 300 Catholic
priests abused more than 1,000 children
since 1947 in six state diocese whorl
was not accused of misconduct but he did
oversee the pittsburgh diocese during
the time several abuses occurred how
does it feel knowing children were
sexually abused at the hands of priests
under your watch we're very very sorry
this happened and that's why we've taken
the steps to see that it doesn't go on
the church now faces another hurdle as a
former papal ambassador to the u.s. is
calling for the Pope to step down
Archbishop Carlo Maria Vigano alleges
Pope Francis willingly took a 2015
meeting with controversial Kentucky
clerk Kim Davis who drew criticism for
refusing to issue same-sex marriage
licenses
the Vatican has maintained Davis was
snuck in by Vigano and the Pope did not
know who she was
it is completely unprecedented for an
ambassador from the Holy See to publicly
accuse the Pope of something like this
the Catholic Church normally operates
behind closed doors we never hear about
these kinds of controversies some
supporters of Pope Francis believe
Archbishop Vigano represents a
conservative sect of the church that
doesn't support Pope Francis's emphasis
on inclusion of the gay community in a
press release Sunday Cardinal Wuerl said
increasingly it is clear that the Pope
is the object of a concentrated attack a
huge crisis for the church that
continues to unfold Niki thank you